allez l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement la première
question va être posée par Monsieur
Roger Vicot pour le groupe
socialiste merci merci madame la
Présidente chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le ministre dans
quelques mois la France accueillera la
plus importante compétition sportive
internationale avec les Jeux olympiques
d'été notre pays s'apprête à cette
occasion à recevoir 16 millions de
touristes lors des débats sur la loi
prévoyant les mesures de sécurité à
mettre en place pour les j notre groupe
a toujours soutenu l'idée que cette
manifestation exceptionnelle justifia
des mesures exceptionnelles tant bien
entendu que les libertés fondamentales
étaient respecté au fil des mois et au
fil des semaines l'inquiétude grandit
sur cette question de la sécurisation
des Jeux Olympiques il y a quelques
jours un touriste allement était
mortellement touché en plein centre de
la capitale vous avez mis en cause
monsieur le ministre le corps médical je
ne crois pas que le débat soit là
puisque quels que soient les
responsabilités les faits sont là on
sait par ailleurs que des milliers et
des milliers d'agents de sécurité
doivent être recrutés pour les j or à 8
mois de la cérémonie d'ouverture sur la
scène pour laquelle on attend plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes la
machine semble considérablement enrayée
les entreprises de sécurité privée
rechigne à s'engager dans un nouveau
partenariat avec l'État n'ayant toujours
pas été payé des prestations de la Coupe
du monde de rugby Paul emploi fait de
son mieux bien entendu mais en poussant
parfois le bouchon très loin on a pu
lire qu'une chanteuse lyrique au chômage
s'est vu proposer un poste de vigile cet
exemple n'est pas rare on cherche à
recruter coûte que coûte quel que soit
le profil et surtout quels que soi les
risques qui sont ainsi pris en tentant
de mettre sur le terrain des personnes
absolument pas formées à des situations
absolument atypique ma question est donc
très simple monsieur le ministre que
comptez-vous faire ferez-vous appel à
l'armée comme on l'entend dire quel est
votre plan de bataille pour que la
France soit prête à temps merci beaucoup
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald armanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outremes merci merci
madame la Présidente mesames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieurs le
député les mêmes critiques et les mêmes
appréhensions ont eu lieu pour la Coupe
du monde de rugby et cette coupe du
monde de rugby grâce au policiers aux
gendarmes grâce aux agents de sécurité
privée s'est déroulé dans de parfaites
conditions de sécurité et salué à
travers le monde je rappelle que pendant
cette couione de rugby qui est le 4e
événement au monde organisé par notre
pays nous avons accueilli le pape
pendant 2 jours à Marseille dans les
quartiers nord et en même temps le roi
et la reine d'Angleterre à travers la
France et pourtant pourtant il y a eu
les drames ignobles qui a connu Israël
la remontée du du terrorisme partout en
Europe vous l'avez vu partout et
notamment à à Bruxelles et et bien sûr
en France à arace des alertes à la bombe
qui ont été multiplié il n'y a pas eu il
n'y a pas eu de désorganisation de la
couponde de Ruby parce que nous avons su
être au rendez-vous alors oui des moyens
exceptionnels seront là pour les Jeux
Olympiques c'est tout à fait vrai le
Parlement par deux fois a voté des
textes qui nous ont aidé intelligence
particulière pour les caméras de
vidéoprection qui vont nous aider je
constate d'ailleurs que vous navez pas
voté à pouvoir moduler un certain nombre
d'actions la présence systématique de
tous les policiers des gendarmes avec la
création de 11 escadrons de gendarmerie
mobile ou de CRS c'est aussi le cas
monsieur le député pardon ce n'est pas
la peine de crier avant d'avoir mal les
16000 agents de sécurité privée déjà
recruté alors que les appels d'offre du
comité d'oranation des Jeux Olympiques
dont c'est la responsabilité n'arrivve à
échéance qu'en février prochain et puis
vous dire que bien sûr que tout le monde
aura une carte professionnelle c'est la
loi sécurité globale que vous n'avez pas
voté non plus monsieur le député en tout
cas votre groupe qui permet à chaque
agent de sécurité privée d'avoir une
carte professionnelle et de ne pas
connaître une sous-traitance au-delà
d'un seul rang ce qui n'était pas le cas
lorsque vous étiez en responsabilité la
vérité monsieur le député c'est que vous
êtes capable dans la même semaine de
refuser au préfet de police un QR code
pour accéder à la cérémonie d'ouverture
et nous demander plus de fermeté il n'y
a pas beaucoup de cohérence dans vot
position merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Fanta
Berr pour le groupe
Renaissance présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outres mèes le métro birakem et le
pont de Grenelle lieu symbolique de ma
circonscription ont été frappé samedi
soir par un homme qui a fait couler le
sang sur nos trottoir toutes mes
condoléances à la famille de la victime
et mes pensées au
blessé Olivier verrand l'a exprimé au
sjet de crépoul ces drames nous font
courir le risque d'un basculement de
notre société si nous nous sommes pas à
la hauteur 78 % des Français partagent
ce propos le risque est immense
l'idéologie des terroristes s'engouffre
dans toutes les brèches elle se sert de
nos failles et met en place un piège du
face- à faceace dans lequel il ne faut
pas tomber nous opposer les uns aux
autres voilà ce qu'ils recherchent et
voilà aussi ce que nous propose le RN
quand on nous dit que la police n'a pas
fait son job je réponds mensonge à aucun
moment les détracteurs le savent il n'y
a eu de raté de services français le job
a été fait quand les agents du 15e et du
7e arrondissement sous le commandement
des commissaires valallot et la combe
ont neutralisé laassaillant rapidement
et sans armes à feu j'aimerais qu'on
leur rende
hommage quand on nous dit que la justice
est l'xiste je réponds mensonge l'homme
a été condamné à 5 ans dont 4 en ferm
qu'il a fait en prison il a suivi le
programme Perse à sa sortie il a été
placé sous contrôle judiciaire soyons à
la hauteur malgré la menace terroriste
durable à laquelle nous faisons face
malgré le contexte social qui met de
l'huile sur le feu malgré les
récupérations politiques et la volonté
de certains de souffler sur les brises
pour diviser et récolter les fruits du
CHA
soyons à la hauteur et ne livre ne
livrons pas nos compatriotes musulmans à
la vindicte populaire le tueur est né à
ne de parents qui ont fuit les mollas
qui ne lui ont pas donné d'éducation
religieuse et qui ont francisé son
prénom la période que l'on traverse est
complexe notre façon de l'aborder
déterminera la nature du prochain cycle
qui va s'ouvrir à nous ma question
monsieur le ministre est la suivante que
répondez-vous au président du RN qui
parle de défaillance politique et
qu'émane-t-il de la réunion de sécurité
qui s'est tenue dimanche
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Gérald armanin ministre de l'Intérieur
et des
outremerses merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Fanta berreté vous avez dans
votre circonscription est celle d'Olivia
Grégoire connu un drame un assassinat un
acte terroriste islamiste
ou un jeune homme en effet allemand est
mort et je veux lui adresser à lui ainsi
qu'à l'ensemble des victimes de cet
attentat les pensées évidemment les plus
fortes quand il y a un attentat quand il
y a un attentat islamiste il y a
toujours à se poser les questions pour
savoir si nous avons bien fait et aucune
question n'est àout pour la sécurité de
nos concitoyens constatons aussi que la
menace islamiste touche partout dans le
monde et que ces attentats sont sur tous
les territoires européens occidentaux et
internationaux et que la prignance de
cette menace terroriste islamiste je
l'ai répété quasiment tous les jours
depuis je su ministreintérieur sera là
pendant longtemps parce que nous devons
lutter contre une idéologie radicale qui
veut en premier lieu nous diviser et qui
veut en premier toucher notre conception
de la liberté et notre protection du
monde il y a dans cet attentat islamiste
plusieurs questions qui se posent
avons-nous tous les moyens de suivi
judiciaire après la condamnation en 2016
et une peine qui a été intégralement
effectué par cette personne nous le
pensons c'est pour ça que nous avons
fait la loi de 2021 que le garde des
saut et je regrette je regrette que tout
le monde ici n''est pas souhaité y
compris Madame Le Pen voter ce texte qui
nous aurait permis sans doute pour les
personnes qui concernent les sorties de
prison après 2021 d'être dans le suivi
judiciaire et suivre cette personne nous
pouvons en effet nous poser des
questions sur l'injonction sur le suivi
psychiatrique et nous connaissons le
travail des médecins psychiatres et des
médecins et la difficulté que nous avons
je remercie ministre de la Santé
désormais de mettre dans tous les
groupements autour des préfets des
médecins psychiatres qui aident et qui a
la GS et bien sûr lutter contre l'islam
radical il ne faut pas trembler pour
lutter contre la haine sur internet pour
lutter contre la haine dans les lieux de
cules pour lutter contre la haine dans
les associations et je m'excuse mais là
quand je vois que des gens nous
combattent sur ce point et ne votent pas
la loi séparatisme je me dis qu'en effet
des gens cherchent à nous diviser et
plutôt à gagner les élections qu' faire
gagner la France Merci Merci monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Alma
Dufour pour le groupe la France
insoumise madame la Première ministre la
trêve est finie les bombardements ont
repris à Gaza l'enfer sur terre est
revenu selon les mot d'une responsable
de l'ONU 1,9 million de Gazaoui se sont
déplacés dans le sud à la demande
d'Israël et c'est désormais le sud qui
est bombardé 16000 personnes ont été
tuées
6150 enfants si les civils ne meurent
pas assassinés par l'armée israélienne
c'est la maladie qui les tuera car
personnes souffrent désormais de
disentriie aigu car l'eau potable manque
à Gaza la colonisation a fait 243 morts
en 6 Jordanie alors que le territoire
n'est pas contrôlé par le Hamas les
attaques au Liban se multiplient et des
milices pro-iraniennes s'en prennent en
retour à des base américaines en Irak et
en Syrie combien de temps allez-vous
laisser netanahou mettre en danger la
sécurité de toute la région vivre dans
une réalité sociale et médiatique
parallèle vous permet sans doute
d'arriver à vous regarder est dans une
glace mais nous nous les voyons les
vidéos qu'on nous envoie tous les jours
de cadavres d'enfants de cadavres
d'enfants avec leur nom écrit sur leur
poignet pour qu'on puisse les identifier
sous les décombres des grands-pères qui
enterrent leur petites filles de 5 ans
des enfants qui disent qu'ils auraient
préféré mourir avec leurs parents cela
fait 50 jours d'horreur que vous arrivez
à dormir la nuit mais les Français n'y
arrivent plus combien m'écrivent parce
qu'ils n'en peuvent plus de votre
lâcheté Emmanuel Macron a demandé le
cesser le feu oui mais quelques jours
après Sébastien leur Cornu s'est
empressé d'aller rassurer Israël du
soutien de la France vous ne pouvez pas
faire Dieu en même temps avec des
massacres d'enfants seuls les actes
comptent seuls les actes comptent il
faut prendre des sanction diplomatique
et économique contre ce gouvernement qui
est un gouvernement d'assassin ne pas le
faire c'est être complice ne pas le
faire c'est tuer ses enfants une seconde
fois je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Laurence B
secrétaire d'État chargé de
l'Europe merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée al du fourour d'abord je vous
prie d'excuser la ministre des Affaires
étrangères Catherine Colona qui comme
vous le savez est en
Australie vous déplorez que la trêve
n'est pas tenue je déplore que vous me
posiez une question de politique
politicienne vous savez très bien que
nous déplorons la
nous saz très bien que la trêve nous
l'avons demandé depuis plusieurs
semaines qu'elle a permis de faire
sortir des otage aux mains du Hamas des
femmes des enfants des personnes âgées
cette rêve elle a permis la libération
de quat de nos otages quatre
compatriotes
elle a aussi permis de faire rentrer de
l'aide humanitaire en plus grand nombre
de faire sortir des blessés qui sont
pris en charge sur un bateau français le
Dick smut qui a été déployé dans l'INF
la fin de l'accord sur les libérations
d'otage c'est un drame pour les otages
et pour leur familles auquel je pense
aujourd'hui parce que quatre Français
sont toujours portés disparus la fin de
l'accord signe aussi la fin de la trêve
et donc de nouvelles souffrances pour
les Palestiniens de Gaza qui subissent
une situation humanitaire catastrophique
nous l'avons toujours dit la France a
toujours appelé au retour de la trêve
elle poursuit son action en faveur des
population civile à Gaza qui n'ont pas
appayé le crime du
Hamas Catherine Colona va tenir demain
une conférence de suivi de la conférence
humanitaire du 9 novembre notamment en
présence de l'ONU et des ONG actifes sur
le terrain et ça sera l'occasion de
faire le point sur les engagements qui
avaient été pris le 9 novembre et
d'avancer dans leur mise en œuvre
concrète au bénéfice des
populations écoutez monsieur au-delà des
à nouveau de vos politiques
politiciennes
de
l'urg la France elle continue de vrai
avec le gouvernement àer le feu qui est
nécessaire comme l'a rappelé le
président de la République mais
peut-être vous n'entendez pas très très
bien et d'ailleurs les consultations se
sont poursuivies au Qatar je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
Président marlex pour le groupe les
républain
min encore une fois la France a été
plongée dans l'horreur par un terroriste
se réclamant de l'État islamique
permettez-moi d'avoir une pensée pour
Coline assassiné alors qu'il découvrait
Paris en amoureux avec sa compagne et de
rendre hommage au sang-froid des
policiers qui ont neutralisé le
tueur
comme le terroriste Damas l'auteur de
cet attentat était parfaitement connu
par les services de police en lien avec
les assassins du père Amel et de Samuel
paatti il a passé 4 ans en prison pour
avoir préparé un attentat il était
depuis suivi par la DGSI il y a moins de
2 mois fin octobre sa mère s'est rendue
dans un commissariat de police pour
demander
à ce qu'il soit mieux surveillé par la
police madame la Première ministre vous
êtes chef du gouvernement à ce titre
vous disposez de l'administration
pouvez-vous nous dire ce qui a été fait
depuis cette visite au commissariat très
bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le Président marlex alors vous
l'avez dit samedi dernier près du pont
birakem un homme a été tué et deux
autres personnes ont été blessées
victimes du terrorisme islamiste je veux
leur rendre hommage je veux dire ma
solidarité et celle de mon gouvernement
à leur famillees et à leurs proches et
je veux saluer à mon tour comme vous
l'avez fait nos forces de l'ordre et nos
services de
secours leur intervention rapide a
permis d'éviter un bilan plus lourd
encore alors monsieur le Président
marlex évidemment comme vous je ne peux
pas me satisfaire que cette personne qui
a fait l'objet d'un suivi judiciaire qui
a fait l'objet d'un suivi administratif
qui était comme vous l'avez évoqué suivi
par nos nos services de renseignement
qui a fait l'objet d'un suivi
psychiatrique soit passé à l'acte et
malheureusement est tué une personne
samedi
dernier pour autant je pense que nous
pouvons reconnaître ensemble que nous
avons considérablement renforcé notre
Arsenal depuis 2017 je pense à la loi
renforçant la sécurité intérieure et la
lutte contre le terrorisme qui a permis
notamment la surveillance des individus
qui présentent une menace qui a permis
la fermeture des lieux de culte où l'on
fait l'apologie du du terrorisme qui
permet la visite des domiciles des
personnes suspectées de représenter une
menace terroriste je pense aussi à la
création du parquet national
antiterroriste en 2019 je pense à la loi
de 2021 qui a permis de créer une mesure
de prévention de la récidif terroriste
en permettant le suivi judiciaire
jusqu'à 5 ans après leur sortie de
prison des individus condamnés je pense
aussi à la loi sur le séparatisme qui
permet de nous attaquer aux racines de
la radicalisation nous avons renforcé le
contrôle des associations je vais venir
monsieur le député nous avons facilité
la fermeture des lieux où l'on porte la
haine de la République et nous avons
créé un nouveau délit de séparatisme
nous avons aussi considérablement
renforcé c'est les moyens de la sécurité
intérieure comme de nos services de
renseignement et cette détermination
elle porte ses fruits puisque 43
attentats ont pu être déjoués depuis
2017 et je pense que ça mérite d'être
souligné alors évidemment suite à ce
drame j'ai réuni le ministre de
l'Intérieur le ministre de la Justice et
le ministre de la Santé pour examiner si
des améliorations peuvent encore être
apporté à notre dispositif alors vous le
dites la mère de ce terroriste avait
signaler sa crainte sur l'évolution de
l'état psychiatrique de son fils nous
lui avons nous lui avons conseillé de
demander un placement d'office de son
fils ce qu'elle a refusé de faire
faut-il compléter notre arsenal
juridique nous aurons à en débattre nous
nous sommes en train de l'examiner et je
peux vous assurer monsieur le Président
marlex que face au terrorisme nous
devons évidemment à chaque fois tirer
les leçons de ce que nous avons pu
constater et nous le ferons monsieur le
député monsieur le président merci
beaucoup madame la Première ministre
monsieur le
Président merci madame la Présidente la
réalité madame la premierre ministre
c'est que l'État ne parvient plus à
protéger les Français en 2023 le nombre
d'homicidees dans notre pays battra tous
les records depuis 50 ans voilà la
vérité les Français attendent
aujourd'hui un changement radical ce
changement il suppose sur la loi
immigration de ne pas détricoter le
texte du Sénat c'est ce que votre
majorité a fait toute la semaine
dernière ce changement suppose d'avoir
le courage de modifier notre code de la
nationalité vous vous y refusez
systématiquement ce changement il
supposera enfin et surtout de modifier
notre Constitution pour reprendre en
main notre souveraineté dans le domaine
de l'immigration là encore vous vous y
refusez il ne sert à rien d'avoir des
ministres qui courent sur les plateaux
de télé pour dire qu'ils n'ont aucun
tabou pour protéger les Français si jeud
dis dans cet hémicycle Vous refusez une
nouvelle fois de modifier notre
Constitution
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Marle je pense que ce débat sur le texte
immigration vous l'aurez dans cette dans
cet hémicycle mais en l'occurrence en
l'occurrence nous parlons d'un
terroriste qui était français je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre s'il vous plaît un peu de
calme PLA s'il vous plaît on va passer
la parole à l'orateur
suivant Monsieur Laurent escenet gox
pour le groupe démocrate merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
priscvenau secrétaire d'État chargé de
la jeunesse et du service national
universel ce weekend plus de 200000
bénévoles partout sur le territoire
lveront des fonds pour le Téléton
partout ces engagés d'un jour ou d'une
vie se mobiliseront contre les des
maladies rares cette collecte populaire
la plus importante au monde et chaque
année un immense succès grâce à eux en
cette Journée mondiale du bénévolat je
leur exprime ma profonde gratitude et je
pense celle de l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale s
présente plus globalement c'est le
travail de tous les bénévoles qu'il faut
saluer moi-même plusieurs fois président
d'association je sais la portée d'un tel
engagement si 11 millions de Français
sont impliqué dans une association ce
chiffre ne doit pas occulter la crise du
bénévolat chez moi dans le loraguet les
associations rurales sont
particulièrement touché mardi dernier
nous avons voté en commission un texte
destiné à lutter contre leur difficultés
quotidiennes de ces associations chevill
ouvrière de la cohésion sociale cette
proposition de loi simplifiera la vie de
ces structures et revalorisera
l'engagement bénévole celle-ci a été
enrichie de mesures que j'ai pu porter
pour le groupe démocrate en en faveur de
la formation des bénévoles concrètement
les nouveaux retraités pourront
mobiliser leur CPF pour acquérir les
compétences et les expertise
indispensable à nos associations c'est
un enjeu cardinal du nouveau souffle
bénévole certains parmi les moins
diplômés n'osent pas franchir le pas de
l'engagement ils ont peur de manquer de
qualification de faire par inadvertance
des erreurs ou des choses prohibées les
compétences manquent alors agissons
madame la ministre en cette Journée
mondiale du bénévolat qu pourrions-nous
prendre dans les semaines et les mois à
venir pour favoriser l'engagement dans
la vie associative comment pouvons-nous
mieux accompagner les bénévoles
notamment dans la gestion financière
humaine et administrative des
associations soutenez-vous notre
ambition de renforcer leur droit à la
formation je vous remercie merci mon
cher collègue la parole est à Madame
frisc ministre en charge de la jeunesse
et du service national
universel merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le députés effectivement
permettez-moi à mon tour en cette
journée du 5 décembre de rendre hommage
à l'ensemble des 15 millions de
bénévoles qui œuvrent quotidiennement
pour notre pays dans nos territoires qui
le font en dépit de leur des polémiques
qu'on pourrait avoir sur leur prénom
leur religion leur origine sociale ou
les territoires où ils habitent ils
œuvrent pour défendre nos valeurs de
fraternité et de solidarité et en ce
sens vous avez raison nous devons
continuer à les valoriser à les
accompagner et effectivement à
simplifier leur vie au quotidien
notamment au travers de la proposition
de loi qui a été portée par l'ensemble
des groupes de la majorité et qui a été
voté à la quasi unanimité il y a
quelques jours en commission cette loi
porte des enjeux concrets celle de
valoriser effectivement le mesénat de
compéten pour les entreprises de moins
de 5000 salariés mais également de
faciliter le recours au con d'engagement
citoyen mais également de permettre la
valorisation sur le compte personnel de
formation les compétences acquis dans le
cadre du bénévolat mais si cette loi
cette proposition de loi nous a réuni
elle doit nous obliger à aller plus loin
et c'est notamment ce que nous avons
fait ce matin avec ma collègue Amélie
oua casterra nous avons ouvert un site
dédié au VAE de bénévola pour permettre
justement de valoriser les compétences
acquises dans le cadre du bénévola sein
de l'entreprise au sein des professions
donc oui continuons à avancer continuons
à valoriser et ne tombons pas dans les
polémiques veines quand il s'agit de
défendre les valeurs de notre République
merci merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à madame la
Présidente Le Pen pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
une nouvelle attaque terroriste
islamiste assumée et revendiquée a
provoqué la mort d'un e allemand est
blessé deux personnes et le bilan n'est
pas plus lourd grâce au courage de nos
forces de l'ordre à chaque attaque les
mêmes question car à chaque attaque on
découvre un auteur connu repéré
surveillé et à chaque attaque les
Français déplore que rien n'a été fait
pour le neutraliser à chaque attaque
aussi nos compatriotes assistent aux
diversions médiatique et
politique non la question n'est pas le
suivi psychiatrique mais bien
neutralisation de quelqu'un dont les
prédispositions idéologiques le parcours
criminel et les revendications sont
parfaitement
cohérents l'islamisme n'est pas regarder
en face mais minoré pas analysé mais
invisibilisé pas affronter mais
contourner et vous feignez d'ignorer
qu'une bonne partie des terroristes est
issue de l'immigration car cela mettrait
en cause les responsabilités passées et
présentes dans la submersion migratoire
que nous subissons
je vous le dis avec gravité et regret
cette dérobade n'est pas responsable en
ce qui nous concerne nous ne nous
déroberons pas nous continuerons de
tenir le langage de vérité et de fermeté
qu'attendent légitimement tous les
français pour combattre l'islamisme je
vous renvoie à ma proposition de loi
visant à combattre les idéologies
islamistes déposé en février
2021 pour combattre les
islamistes nous avons là aussi des
mesures expulser ceux qui sont étrangers
pour menaces grave à l'ordre public ou
terrorisme d choir de leur nationalité
les binationaux comme c'est le cas du
terroriste du pont birakem puis les
expulser poursuivre les nationaux pour
intelligence avec l'ennemi après avoir
dressé une liste d'organisation ennemie
de la France les solutions efficaces et
dissuasives existent madame la Première
ministre êtes-vous prête à prendre ces
mesures et à les mettre en œuvre
merci la parole est à Madame la prière
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente Le Pen quand la France est
touchée il y a ceux qui agissent en
responsabilité et puis il y a vous et
votre parti qui une nouvelle fois vous
précipitez dans le seul but d'alimenter
les polémiques vous qui ne respectez
jamais le travail des enquêteur et de la
justice et tirez toujours les
conclusions sans même connaître les
faits vous qui remettez en cause parce
que c'est bien ce que vous faites le
travail de nos services de renseignement
et de nos forces de l'ordre alors depuis
2017 madame la Présidente Le Pen malgré
une menace qui ne cesse de se renouveler
et de s'adapter 43 attentats ont été
déjoués 1500 personnes ont été
interpellés et présentés devant la
justice pour des faits de terrorisme et
pendant ce temps Madame la Présidente Le
Pen où étiez-vous où étiez-vous en 2017
avec vos députés lors du vote de la loi
renf forçant la sécurité intérieure et
la lutte contre le terrorisme une loi
qui permet de fermer les lieux de culte
où l'on propage la haine et qui facilite
les mesures de surveillance individuelle
vous ne l'avez pas voté où étiez-vous en
2019 quand nous avons créé le parquet
national antiterroriste vous avez voté
contre où étiez-vous en 2021 quand nous
avons créé le délit de séparatisme et
que nous avons étendu le fichier des
auteurs d'infraction aux apologies et
provocation au terrorisme vous ne l'avez
pas voté où étiez-vous quand nous avons
donné des moyens inédits à nos services
de renseignement tous ces budgets avec
vos députés vous vous y êtes opposé
alors madame Le Pen les faits sont
simples le rassemblement national c'est
systématiquement opposé aux mesures pour
renforcer la protection des Français
systématiquement opposer aux mesures
pour renforcer la lutte contre le
terrorisme nous agissons vous vous
polémiquez nous pr prenons des mesures
vous êtes dans la posture vos votes
parlent de même nous nous sommes du côté
des actes nous prenons nos
responsabilités pour protéger les
Français je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Frédéric maillot pour le groupe
GDR madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues nous sommes le 5 décembre 2023
et il y a 10 ans nous quitait un grand
homme un grand chef d'État que j'aime
appeler Madiba mais plus connu sur le
nom de Nelson Mandela c'était un homme
de paix un homme qui a combattu
l'apartide la discrimination et
l'oppression de son peuple cet homme que
l'Occident aimait décrire comme
terrorisme mais qui a finalement vu
l'histoire lui donner raison jusqu'à
devenir prix Nobel de la paix en 93
Madiba a fait de sa vie un combat pour
la paix adepte de la nonvolence la
nonvolence c'est le but auquel je
souscris car il nous faut avancer vers
la paix est-ce un hasard du calendrier
si cela fera dans 2 jours que le conflit
israëlo palestinien entent nos débats de
mois que ces images d'horreur occupent
nos esprits et nos consciences mes chers
collègues face à l'horreur ne faisons
pas partie de ceux qui se contentent de
px de peu nous ne voulons plus d'une
trêve nous voulons la paix nous ne
voulons pas d'annonce présidentielle
sans effet nous voulons la paix nous ne
voulons pas voir couler le sang et les
larmes nous voulons la paix nous ne
voulons pas que les enfants grandissent
sous le bruit des bombes nous voulons la
paix loin de moi d'émettre des vœux à la
Miss France je veux ici parler de
solutions politiques concrète
c'est pourquoi j'interpelle le
gouvernement madame la Première ministre
quelle solution la France a-t-elle prévu
de mettre en ure pour faire avancer la
paix qu'est-ce que la France prendra
quand est-ce que la France prendra sa
part pour l'arrêt des massacres inhumain
qui touche des vies innocentes j'ai
commencé avec Madiba je vais terminer
avec celui-ci nous savons très bien que
notre liberté est incomplète sans la
liberté des Palestiniens je l'affirme
ici là où il pas de justice il n'y a pas
de paix battons-nous battons-nous pour
qu' devienne la paix merci beaucoup la
parole est à Madame Laurence B ministre
en charge de
l'Europe merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs député monsieur le
député Frédéric maillot je l'ai dit
précédemment nous avons demandé la trêve
nous continuons de demander la trêve et
nous continuons de parler de paix c'est
d'abord c'est d'abord drame pour les
familles des otages pour les familles
des porté disparu et je voudrais que
nous ayons une pensée pour nos quatre
compatriotes qui sont toujours
disparus leur libération et nous le
demandons doit intervenir immédiatement
la prise d'otage c'est un crime AB
contraire à toutes les normes de la
morale et du troit la position de la
France Monsieur a toujours été très
claire elle repose sur trois piliers
sécuritaire humanitaire et
politique sécuritaire nous l'avons dit
c'est le droit d'Israël de se défendre
dans le respect du droit international
humanitaire
humanitaire je le répète humanitaire
c'est la protection des civils à Gaza
C'est la trêve que nous avons demandé
encore et toujours et enfin politique
car il n'y aura pas de paix sans
solution politique à deux états et la
France a toujours été extrêmement claire
et à œuvré sur ce sujet je vous remercie
de m'avoir écouté merci
beaucoup 2
secondes
mais vous étiez à moins non non vous
aviez écoulé votre temps désolé la
parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane vous aviez même eu du rab la
parole est à Monsieur Stéphane vogetta
pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
cette question s'adresse à à Gérald
armanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outres mèes ce dimanche routel CRIF
faisait tout simplement son métier de
journaliste soumettant à ses questions
sans concession le député bonpard
Jean-Luc Mélanchon a réagit
immédiatement sur X ex Twitter en taxant
madame elcriev je cite de manipulatrice
et de fanatiqu qui méprise les musulmans
lundi dernier c'était le journaliste
Patrick Cohen qui évoquait le drame de
crpo
aussitôt une députée du rassemblement
national a saisi publiquement l'arcom
sur une séquence qui faisait selon elle
la honte de l'audiovisuel public samedi
monsieur Cohen était attaqué verbalement
et faisait objet de menace dans
plusieurs manifestations d'extrême
droite il est choquant il est choquant
de voir des responsables politiques
proférer des appels à peine voilés à la
haine des journalistes particulièrement
dans le climat actuel certes les
méthodes évoluent fin les lettres de
dénonciation anonyme c'est désormaise
l'on utilise pour coller une cible dans
le dos de celles et ceux qui nous
déplaisent pour désigner à la vindicte
populaire les journalistes qui posent
les mauvaises questions tout comme les
députés qui votent mal et cela alors que
selon l'Unesco 86 journalistes ont été
assassinés dans le monde en 2022 dont la
moitié en dehors de l'exercice de leur
fonction avons-nous déjà oublié Charli
Hebdo ceux qui attaquent ainsi des
journalistes n'ontil donc rien appris
des mécanismes de la haine nous trompons
pas l'incitation à la haine et à la
violence n'a rien à voir avec la liberté
d'expression chers collègues il s'agit
d'une infraction punie par nos lois et
qui constitue même un délis soumis à des
peines d'emprisonnement si cette
incitation est publique alors Monsieur
le Ministre ma question est la suivante
comment pouvons-nous collectivement
défendre la liberté de la presse et que
peut faire le gouvernement pour protéger
toutes celles et ceux qui l'incarnent et
une question subsidiaire à défaut de
poursuite judiciaire faudrait-il que
Monsieur Mélenchon et les responsables
politiques qui incitent à la violence
soient déjà fich je vous remercie merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
armanin ministre de l'intérieurs et des
outres
m merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
vogetta les policiers les gendarmes du
service de la protection des
personnalités n'agissent pas parce
qu'ils soutiennent tel ou tel courant de
pensée religion opinion politique ou
action
tel ou tel journaliste ils sont là pour
protéger ceux qu'ils sont menacés c'est
le cas des responsables religieux juifs
ou musulmans au moment où nous parlons
c'est le cas d'opposants politiques qui
trouvent refuge dans notre pays c'est le
cas des membres du gouvernement comme
des responsables de l'opposition c'est
le cas de magistrats antiterroristes
comme de
journalistes monsieur Boyard par exemple
a pu être protégé par la police et c'est
l'honneur de la police que de le
protégersieur B a pu être protégé par la
police c'est l'UR de lace protégé
monsieur Zemour est actuellement protégé
par la police et c'est normal que les
gens qui soient menacés parce qu'ils ont
des opinions parce que d'autres leur
mettent des cibles sur le dos le soir
par les policiers qui je ici je veux le
redire risquent leur vie comme ce
policier qui est mort à charlieb pour
protéger des journalistes dans leur
action Kef a déjà été sous protection
policière par le passé elle a déjà été
menacée par des menaces extrêmement
sérieuses analysé par la DGSI par le
service particulier qui regarde les
menaces pour déclencher les protections
qui s'appellent luclat elle a eu de très
nombreuses menaces de mort et pendant
des jours et des nuits elle et sa
famille comme d'autres journalistes je
l' dit ont pu être protégés ces menaces
se sont amoindries avec le temps et sa
protection a été levée il est certain
que d'après les analyses du ministère de
l'Intérieur
les propos de Monsieur Mélenchon qui lui
met ni plus ni moins qu'une cible sur le
dos mérite la protection de la
République et j'appelle chacune et
chacun ici à mesurer les propos publics
que l'on peut
tenir et ce sera le cas pour toute
personne quel que soit ces opinions qui
sera menacé ce sera l'honneur de la
police de les protéger et compris quand
ses dirigeants de la France insoumise
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la
parole un peu de silence la parole est à
Monsieur Paul André Colombani pour le
groupe
lot merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre de la Santé chers collègues
je connais bien le secret médical qui
s'impose à moi dans ma profession mais
le secret statistique je n'en avais
jamais entendu parler probablement parce
qu'il n'existe pas c'est pourtant ce que
nous a opposé l'administration pour ne
pas transmettre les données d'une étude
de surprenante affirmant qu'il n'était
pas nécessaire de rehausser les
coefficients géographiques en Corse en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique ces
coefficients ont pour but je le rappelle
de compenser les surcûts liés à
l'insularité qui explique la finance la
situation financière dégradée dans
laquelle se trouvent nos hôpitaux il est
néanmoins impératif que la méthode de
calcul de ce coefficient soit
transparente et cohérente c'est un BIA
statistique majeur que de penser que le
surcoup peut se limiter à l'effet prix à
savoir les différences de coût à volume
équivalent c'est ignoré que l'essentiel
des activités et des charges àenantes
exige une prise en compte des volumes
réalisés largement inférieurs aux
standards hexagonaux en raison des
contraintes démographiques et
géographiques à ce titre l'analyse des
40 premiers groupes homogènes de malades
par établissement est édifiante
12341 patients en moyenne sur le
continent contre par exemple 7133 pour
les établissements en de Corse de ce
fait les surcouts sont principalement
constitué d'une moindre utilisation des
plateaux techniques je peux vous prendre
un exemple très parlant enc nous faisons
27 protèse de hanche par établissement
contre 131 sur le continent et il nous
est impossible de regrouper ces
établissement ce type d'intervention en
raison de contraintte géographiques dès
lors il me semble urgent d'associer la
Corse à la mission flash relative à la
réévaluation des coefficients
géographiques insulaires dont elle est
aujourd'hui exclu nous pourrionss ainsi
avec nos amis ultramarins faire valoir
une évolution de ces coefficients en
adéquation avec nos besoins et nos
spécificités je vous remercie merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau ministre de
la santé et de la
prévention merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le le député vous vous évoquez
la situation de la du coefficient
géographique permettez-moi d'abord
d'avoir une pensée pour tous les
personnels de l'hôpital d'Ajaccio qui
ont fait face cette nuit à une une
grosse inondation avec une coupure
d'électricité qui ont mis en place tous
les dispositifs pour évacuer les
patients sans aucun risque et qui sont
encore aujourd'hui en train à à cette
heure de réparer les les avaries vous
avez évoqué monsieur le le le député une
étude de l'adresse en effet qui a conclu
que sur la Corse et deux départements
ultramarin il n'était pas nécessaire de
réviser le coefficient géographique mais
qui a conclu que sur deux d'entre eux la
Guyane et la Réunion il était précis
précisément nécessaire de revoir à la
hausse ce coefficient géographique cette
étude n'est pas une étude secrète c'est
précisément après nos premiers échanges
dès ma nomination que j'ai demandé à
l'adresse de vérifier qu'il n'y ait pas
de gros écarts ou de ou de ou de
problèmes de comptabilisation et c'est
un premier regard qu'ils ont fourni je
suis évidemment tout à fait prêt à ce
que cette étude vous soit fourni petit
un parce qu'il n'y a pas de confiance s'
il n'y a pas de la transparence et donc
vous serit évidemment associé
deuxièmement je suis tout à fait prêt
aussi à ce que cette étude qui a été
faite par les services du ministère à ma
demande elle soit challengée pour parler
en bon français et notamment des
particularités que connaît que connaît
la Corse et enfin je je le je le dis
effectivement il y a une mission flash
et mes équipes et moi recevrons bientôt
vos collègues ultramarin et je pense que
le coefficient géographique doit aussi
embarquer les sujets spécifiques à la
course je voudrais dire simplement en
conclusion monsieur le le député que
vous le savez il n'y a pas que le
coefficient géographique pour prendre en
compte les spécificité insulaire
l'hôpital d'Ajaccio dont je parlais en
commençant a été financé à 100 % 175
millions d'euros par l'État c'est la
manifestation de notre engagement au
côté de votre île merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Jean-Claude rau pour le
groupe
écologiste merci Madame présidente
monsieur le ministre de la Santé la
messe c'est une bouffonne c'est une
grosse dès que je sors je vais la
buter ces mots ce sont ceux adressés
hier à Marie Alexis Lefeuvre maire de la
commune de safré ma commune cette
nouvelle menace on ne peut plus
explicite contre une élu aurait pu être
évité elle provient d'un jeune homme
sous curatel nécessitant des soins
psychiatriques mais plus ou moins livré
à lui-même depuis 2 ans des signalement
il y en a eu des dépôts de plainte des
passages à l'acte comme de la torture
sur des animaux entre autres laisser
dépérir la psychiatrie c'est accroître
la violence dans notre
société c'est accepté que les élus se
retrouvent en première ligne prennent
les coups et risquent même leur peau
c'est accepté le suicide d'une jeune
fille dans mon département après qu'elle
a été violée dans une unité pour adultes
alors qu'elle aurait dû être prise en
charge dans un service psychiatrique
pour mineurs c'est accepté l'emprise des
idéologies terroristes sur des jeunes
psychologiquement
fragiles les politiques sécuritaires qui
ont un bon écho ici se contentent de
réprimer de punir et de réagir vous
oubliez qu'une politique de santé
publique contribu à l'apaisement de la
société et à la prévention des
violences votre action à l'égard de la
santé mentale conduit à la fermeture de
lit dans les services 43 àau 28 àan 42
auan 26 30 à montauan et la liste est
loin très loin d'être close notre
contexte c'est celui du manque de
soignant qui s'aggrave puisque la Py
pchiatrie demeure à la fin à la toute
fin des spécialités choisies par les
futurs médecins 40e place sur 44 en
Loire Atlantique la pénuriie médicale
dans les services de l'hôpital de Blin
attant atteint maintenant 50 %. au CHU à
Nant 54 postes infirmiers manqu en PSI
avec ma collègue Julie laernos nous
alertons sans cesse sur la situation en
Pays de la Loire la crise est nationale
les implications la gestion des drames
sont locales faudra-t-il attaquer l'État
pour non assistance à personnees en
danger pour enfin remettre du soin la
place de la violence merci beaucoup mon
cher collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Aurélien Rousseau ministre de la santé
et de la prévention madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député votre raccourci entre
les actes insoutenables que vous avez
décrit et votre phrase sur le fait que
le gouvernement laisserait dépérir la
psychiatrie s'il n était s'il n était
s'il n' était dérisoire il serait
honteux le vous vous avez évoqué toute
une série de choses monsieur le monsieur
le député le le gouvernement depuis 3
ans l'ondame et l'objectif psychiatrie a
augmenté de 33 %. petit 1 petit 2 et
vous avez raison c'est une des
spécialités médicales qui est choisie en
dernier par les internes nous ne pouvons
pas les forcer mais nous avons pu
aujourd'hui baisser de 16 % c'était le
nombre de postes qui n'était pas choisis
à l'issue de l'internat à 5 % et tout ce
que vous décrivez monsieur le député
tout ce que décrivent les élus locaux ça
n'est pas une question que psychiatrique
et dans tout ce que vous avez évoqué
justement il est pour moi trop facile de
considérer que c'it qu'une question
psychiatrique c'est précisément parce
qu'on a laisser tout ça à la psychiatrie
qu'on s'est trompé c'est un sujet de
santé mentale qui aujourd'hui nous nous
prenons tout collectivement en pleine
figure et ce que nous devons réinventer
c'est la gradation de la prise en charge
le bon soin avec le bon soin ign an au
bon moment et en effet il y a une grande
différence entre la personne qui va
faire une décompensation dans l'espace
public avec un épisode aigu tout d'un
coup et le malade qui est hospitalisé en
soins psychiatrique aujourd'hui
l'engagement du gouvernement il est
total je l'ai indiqué lors de la DG je
l'ai indiqué lors de la discussion
générale du PLFSS et vous pourrez crier
madame pendant que je vous réponds
l'engagement du gouvernement il est
total pour que le prochain PLFSS porte
encore plus les enjeux de santé mentale
mais aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
reconstituer par les infirmiers en
pratique avancée en santé mentale par
les psychologues en pratique avancé par
les psychiatres que nous recrutons par
les secouristes en santé mentale toute
une série de réponses qui n'existait pas
alors non nous ne laissons pas dépérir
la psychiatrie monsieur le déput merci
Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur Roger
chudau pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre de
l'éducation nationale les résultats de
PISA 2023 viennent de tomber nous
pouvons baptiser ce nouveau désastre
éducatif génération Hollande les élèves
de 15 ans qui ont été testés sont en
effet entrés dans notre système éducatif
en
2013-24 encore bravo aux socialistes et
au macroniste pendant 6 ans vous n'avez
rien fait de sérieux le dédoublement en
Rep a provoqué un simple frémissement et
vous tentez aujourd'hui une de vos
opérations de communication et de
diversion regardons de près les mesures
que vous annoncez au primaire allègement
des programmes alléger des programmes
quand nos enfants savent déjà si peu de
choses je vous recommande plutôt de
supprimer les pseudos enseignement qui
défigureent l'école primaire et dont
vous êtes effriant éducation sexuelle
lutte contre d'imaginaire phobie pseudo
développement durable vous verrez ça ira
tout de suite beaucoup mieux au collège
vous rétablissez enfin les les groupes
de niveau matière autoriser le
redoublement transformer le DNB en
examen de passage en seconde je vois que
vous connaissez le fonctionnement d'un
photocopieur car ces mesures sont égal
exactement celles du programme éducatif
de Marine Le Pen vous avez de bonnes
lectures compliment donc et
permettez-moi quelques conseils vous
décidez que l'enseignement des
mathématiques doit être prioritairement
rénové soit mais que ne le faites-vous
aussi pour le celui du français
avez-vous parlé du désastre de
l'orthographe ou de ou de l'histoire de
France enfin comment voulez-vous rénover
l'enseignement sans repenser totalement
la formation initiale des professeurs
qui est confié aux inspect qui sont les
organismes de formatage logique qui ne
prépare nullement nos professeurs à leur
métier ou leurs fonction enfin il ne
vous aura pas échappé que les auteurs
des attentats émeutes et attaque des
dernières années des derniers mois sont
tous passés par l'école vous ne dites
pas un mot de l'enseignement dispensé en
Rep ni dans nos 300 quartiers
prioritaires de la ville pas un mot sur
l'échec de l'assimilation par l'école
pas de plan d'urgence pour les écoles et
les collèges de ces quartiers qui sont
des véritables COCOT minute social et et
qui sont travaillés en profondeur par
l'islamisme radical au total votre
opération de communication
mercicoup la parole est à Monsieur
Gabriel hatal ministre de la jeunesse et
de l'éducation
nationale merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Roger chudau les
résultats de PISA sont effectivement
tombés aujourd'hui il confirme le
résultat des évaluations que j'avais
présenté en transparence il y a quelques
semaines et nous avons eu l'occasion
d'en débat effectivement les élèves qui
ont passé PISA l'année dernière étaient
en 6e en 2017 moment où nous avons
réinvesti massivement sur l'école
primaire et nous voyons que le
réinvestissement massif sur l'école
primaire de cette majorité depuis 2017
commence à porter ses fruits vous avez
parlé de frémissement je trouve que
c'est finalement assez négatif pour les
enseignants eux-mêmes qui permettent au
niveau en primaire de commencer à
s'élever il faut évidemment poursuivre
aller plus loin sur le primaire
transformer profondément notre
organisation au collège améliorer notre
organisation au lycée c'est ce que j'ai
présenté ce matin aux enseignants il
faudrait bien plus de 2 minutes pour
rentrer dans le détail mais au fond je
crois qu'il y a une philosophie qui est
importante c'est celle d'une école de la
sincérité et de la vérité la sincérité
la vérité c'est la première maque du
respect et je pense de l'élévation du
niveau quand on dit à un élève qui ne
sait pas lire à la fin de son CP qu'il
peut passer en CE1 quel message on lui
envoie qu'on ne croit pas en lui quand
on dit à des familles que cit qui ont le
dernier mot sur le redoublement quel
message on envoie aux enseignants qu'on
ne croit pas en eux quand on dit que des
résultats aux épreuves du brevet et du
baccalauréat peuvent être
artificiellement modifiés et corrigés
pour atteindre un taux de réussite qui
est souhaité quel message on envoie à la
Jeunesse et à la société qu'on ne croit
pas à la valeur du diplôme qu'on ne
croit pas au travail et au mérite à
l'école ce sont tous ces tabout sous
l'autorité de la Premier ministre et du
président de la République que je
souhaite briser avec des mesures
extrêmement concrètes sur lesquelles
nous aurons l'occasion de revenir avec
d'autres questions mais dans un seul et
même objectif celui de permettre à tous
nos élèves de réussir c'est la meilleure
condition pour que notre pays puisse
réussir dans les années à venir je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à madame Isabelle
roche pour le groupe horizon merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
les livraisons de l'étude PISA sont
rarement agréables à France et ce mésime
2023 ne déroge malheureusement pas à ce
constat dans un contexte général de
baisse globale de la performance des
systèmes éducatif de
l'OCDE baisse de 15 points en
mathématique et de 10 points en
compréhension et de l'écrit baisse
encore plus marqué en France avec une
proportion d'élèves peu performants qui
progressent tandis que celle d'élèves
très performants régressent l'état de
notre école les savoirs de nos enfants
inquiètent les Françaises et les
Français monsieur le ministre et
participe à cette désagréable impression
de déclassement dont il nous parle
en face notre groupe se félicite des
annonces que vous venez de faire pour
rétablir l'autorité des professeurs
offrir de meilleures conditions
d'apprentissage se concentrer sur les
savoirs fondamentaux refondre des
programmes annonce qui complètent celle
déjà faite sur la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire et les carrières
des enseignants avec lucidité nous avons
des obstacles à franchir pour gagner ce
choc des savoirs que vous souhaitez
initier certains de ces obstacles sont
sociétaux la place des écrans la
confiance dans dans l'avenir la
transmission parentale d'autres sont
organisationnell un professeur face à
chaque enfant les bonnes méthodes les
bons manuels et les troisièmes tiennent
de principe le respect du professeur la
valeur du diplôme le passage du concret
à l'abstrait monsieur le ministre
sommes-nous condamnés à observer cette l
de chute à chaque livraison PISA et
comment pouvons-nous principalement au
collège à inverser la donne comment
assurer aux françaises et aux Français
nous serons désormais en mesure de
regagner notre
rang merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la présidente Isabelle roche parmi tous
les points que vous avez évoqué je veux
m'arrêter sur la question des
mathématiques parce qu'une grande nation
c'est une nation mathématique et qu'on
peut pas se satisfaire de la chute du
niveau en mathématique encore constaté à
l'occasion des résultats de PISA très
concrètement j'ai annoncé un certain
nombre de mesures pour relever le niveau
des élèves français en mathématique ça
commence à l'école primaire avec des
manuels en mathématiques labellliser
avec les enseignements de la science et
de la pratique et dont seront doté
toutes les écoles primaires pour au
moins CP et CE1 première chose deuxème
chose les groupes de niveau au collège
pour enfin réussir à faire progresser
tous les élèves alors même que la trop
grande hétérogénéité dans les classes
aujourd'hui conduit certains à stagner
et empêche les autres de s'envoler nous
aurons des groupes de niveau en
mathématiqu enfin au lycée avec Carole
grandan nous allons renforcer le volume
horaire en terminal professionnel des
mathématiques dispenser les
enseignements de mathématique et de
français en petit groupe pour la seconde
et la première professionnelle et enfin
j'assume le souhait que la France adopte
désormais la méthode de Singapour pour
l'enseignement des mathématiques cette
méthode qui a fait ses preuves dans 70
pays autour de nous qui a été construite
en s'inspirant également des racines
françaises et de Ferdinand Buisson qui
lui-même affirmait qu'il faut commencer
par le concret avant l'imager puis
l'abstrait nous allons progressivement
l'adopter en commençant dès septembre
prochain pour CP CE1 et nous allons
désormais créer une nouvelle épreuve
anticipée de mathématiques en fin de
première pour tous les élèves nous avons
aujourd'hui une épreuve anticipée de
français pour tous les élèves en fin de
première car nous considérons à juste
titre que la maîtrise du français est
fondamentale dans le socle de culture
commune de nos élèves je l'affirme notre
culture commune elle est aussi
scientifique et donc désormais
l'ensemble des élèves en fin de première
auront une épreuve anticipée de
mathématique pour réhausser notre niveau
d'exigence je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour ces annonces
et pour ce programme ambitieux et notre
groupe sera à vos côtés pour soutenir
cette politique merci merci beaucoup la
parole est à Monsieur Hugo bernalissis
pour le groupe la France
insoumise madame la Présidente la Cour
de Justice de la République a prononcé
la relax d'Éric Dupont Moretti garde des
se au ministre de la
Justice nous voilà face à une dcision
abracadeabrantesque rendu notamment par
des collègues ici présents qui
constatent noir sur blanc que je cite
l'élément matériel des délis de prise
illégale d'intérêt visé à la prévention
apparaît établi à l'égard du prévenu
mais mais qui n'entre pas en voie de
condamnation je cite toujours à défaut
de caractérisation de l'élément
intentionnel car attention tenez-vous
bien le ministre n'avait pas je cite
toujours la conscience suffisante de
s'exposer à la commission de
l'infraction refusant d'appliquer en
conséquence la jurisprudence pourtant
constante de la Cour de cassation le
voici malgré lui condamné à l'innocence
un véritable bras d'honneur à l'idée de
justice ainsi qu'à la cohérence du droit
avec cette erreur manifeste de droit le
pourvoir en cassation semblait évident
et pourtant ce lundi par la voix même du
procureur général Remi à rebours de ses
propres réquisitions d'un un an de
prison avec surcis a proposé de tourner
la page de regarder vers l'avenir
paraphrasant le garde des sauts quant à
eux les plaignants lésés ne peuvent pas
se pourvoir en cassation du fait de la
procédure de la CJR s'il y a une page à
tourner c'est celle de la CJR qui a fait
la démonstration de son échec les
macronistes proposaient déjà de la
supprimer lors de la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2018 et bien que je
prendne une normalisation du traitement
judiciaire des membres du gouvernement
il est nécessaire de maintenir une
certaine spécificité afin de renforcer
la légitimité démocratique et de
garantir l'impartialité et
l'indépendance de la justice alors
madame la Première ministre allez-vous
proposer un projet constitutionnel
supprimant la Cour de Justice de la
République est comprenant la formation
de jugement avec un jury populaire car
qui de mieux que le peuple pour juger
cell et ceux qui le représent
l'alignement des règles de nomination du
parquet sur celle du siège ou encore le
rattachement de la police judiciaire à
la magistrature
bra je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Franck
Riester ministre en charge des relations
avec le Parlement
merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député
bernalissis vous n'êtes ni procureur ni
juge avec votre question monsieur le
député Bernard Isis vous piétinez
l'autorité de la chose jugé comme vous
avez piétiné pendant des mois la
présomption
d'innocence
comme vous le savez la Cour de Justice
de la République est une juridiction
composée de magistrats professionnels et
de parlementaires de tous les groupes y
compris le vôtre dois-je vous rappeler
que madame auonau était une des
juges après une enquête par la
commission d'instruction puis une
audience avec l'audition de nombreux
témoins elle a délibéré et elle a
décider la relaxe du garde des saau hier
le procureur général de la Cour de
cassation à annoncé qu'il ne formerait
pas de pourvoir contre cette décision
elle est donc
définitive nous devons respecter nos
procédures monsieur le député notre
droit et notre Constitution nous n'avons
pas commenter des décisions de justice
encore une fois nous devons respecter
l'autorité de la chose jugée le ministre
de la Justice est à la tâche comme
depuis le premier jour dans le CRE de la
feuille de route qui lui a été fixé par
le président de la République et la
première ministre alors Monsieur le
Député
bernalis vous me demandez si la Cour de
Justice de la République doit être
supprimé c'est un débat constitutionnel
qui a déjà été posé des réflexions ont
eu lieu dans le cadre des états généraux
de la justice il s'agirait d'une réforme
constitutionnelle majeure qui toucherait
au principe cardinal de la séparation
des pouvoirs elle nécessiterait alors
des concertation danse et une forme de
consensus politique monsieur le député
Bernal
la justice a tranché
respectezla merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre monsieur le
député moi aussi je vais vous répondre
de manière très relaxe je pense qu'il
faut supprimer la Cour de Justice de la
République comme vous le proposiez avec
un jury populaire vous devrez en
répondre devant le
peuple je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Fabiane
colbog pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Madame la
Ministre pris chargé de la jeunesse et
du SNU en ce jour de la journée mondiale
du bénévolat et du volontariat je
voudrais ici exprimer toute notre
connaissance et notre soutien à nos 15
millions de bénévoles ils sont des
maillons essentiels de notre société ils
sont ceux qui font la différence ceux
qui créent des liens ceux qui
transformment des vies Mesdames et
Messieurs les engagés vous que vous
soyez bénévolle au sein de petites ou
grandes associations votre engagement
est immense nous l'avons vu encore ce
matin à l'île Saint-Denis madame la
ministre Amélie oua Castera lors de
votre belle événement sur le bénévolat
sportif nous devons cependant
reconnaître que l'engagement bénévole
est parfois découragé par des obstacles
administratifs financiers ou humains dès
2017 nous avons agi pour accompagner et
soutenir nos associations je pense au
capasso au guide assaut mais aussi au
fond de développement de la vie
associative qui est d'ailleurs abondé
dans le cadre du PLF 2024 de 20 millions
d'euros supplémentaires avec la
proposition de loi de mon collègue
Quentin bataillon nous portons des
mesures concrètes visant à valoriser et
simplifier la vie associative par ces
mesures adoptées en commission je
retiens l'assouplissement des conditions
pour acquérir des droits à la formation
via le compte d'engagement citoyen la
dynamisation du recours au congés
d'engagement associatif et l'ouverture
du mesénat de compéten aux entreprises
de moins de 5000 salariés enfin je tiens
à vous remercier madame la ministre pour
votre infatigable engagement en faveur
de la vie associative et pour les
bénévoles j'aimerais vous interroger sur
l'engagement des jeunes on entend
souvent qu'il ne s'engage plus et
pourtant à mon échelle j'ai monté un
conseil de circonscription des jeunes et
je peux vous dire leur détermination à
vouloir se rendre utile madame la
ministre quel retour avez-vous des
jeunes au regard de vos nombreux
déplacements je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la députée la parole est
à
Madame charge de la jeunesse et du SNU
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Fabiane kolbock effectivement
aujourd'hui à nouveau c'est l'occasion
de saluer l'engagement de nos bénévoles
je l'ai fait tout à l'heure et je pense
que vous l'avez refait à votre tour mais
si nous devons saluer le fait que nous
sommes une nation engagée
fondamentalement engagé et bénévole nous
ne devons pas oublier que nombreux de
nos bénévoles sont des jeunes des très
très jeunes nous avons pu le voir ce
matin ensemble à lî- Saint-Denis j'ai pu
le voir à nîes à Toulouse à Lyon à Lille
nos jeunes s'engagent au travers du
tissu associaciatif mais également au
travers du service civique et du service
national universel le service national
universel j'aime à le rappeler n'est pas
simplement l'alpha et l'oméga de
l'engagement mais bien le début le pied
d'entrée dans un engagement par l'action
dans une démarche de résilience et
d'ambition que nous devons porter
collectivement récemment notre pay pays
a à nouveau été frappé par des
intempéries et à ce titre de nombreux
jeunes mais également de nombreux
députés m'ont sollicité pour savoir
comment nous pouvions mobiliser ces
jeunes dans le cadre du SNU en dehors du
standard habituel j'ai donc décidé de
créer des brigades citoyenne SNU qui
permettent à nos jeunes je suis heureuse
que les bands de la gauche saluent ces
brigades et dans dans le cadre de ces
brigade citoyenne SNU nos jeunes ont pu
venir en renfort des maires des élus
locaux une fois les lieux sécurisés pour
aller recréer du lien là où nous avions
effectivement nos concitoyens peut-être
un peu apurés un peu éloignés je pense
que nous devons collectivement non pas
crier sur notre jeunesse mais en être
fier la mettre au devant de la scène où
qu'ell soit et qu'ell s'engage vers
différents vecteurs différents lieux et
pas simplement des voies que vous auriez
choisi pour eux car oui notre jeunesse
est libre et engagée et nous devons
pouvoir l'honorer merci beaucoup madame
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Franck
gilletti pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outres maires lundi
prochain débutera dans cet hémicycle
l'examen d'un projet de loi ayant
vocation à contrôler plus fermement
l'immigration une bien belle perspective
si cette volonté était non seulement
traduite par des dispositions utiles
mais surtout si cela n'épargnait pas un
pays en particulier l'Algérie alors que
les Algériens forment la première
communauté étrangère en France et la
deuxième nationalité à laquelle on
délivre des titres de séjour
l'immigration algérienne se voit
faciliter et encouragé par l'existence
du traité franco-algérien de 1968 traité
que votre gouvernement n'a toujours pas
remis en cause une complaisance non
partagé par le régime d'Alger qui pour
sa part refusait encore en mars dernier
de délivrer les laisser passer
consulaires permettant le retour des
Algériens expulsés de France une
attitude d'autant plus étonnante quand
on sait qu'il existe une discrimination
positive à l'écart des immigrés
algériens vis-à-vis des autres
nationalités à titre d'exemple rappelons
qu'en terme de liberté d'établissement
ces derniers sont les seul dispensés de
prouver la viabilité de leur projet
contrairement aux autres étrangers de
même l'immigré algérien qui voudrait
obtenir un certificat de résidence avec
son conjoint n'est pas tenu d'apporter
la preuve d'un minimum de 6 mois de vie
commune bien sûr monsieur le ministre
nous savons qu'en général la volonté du
ministère de l'Intérieur se heurte vite
aux impératifs du qu d'orsé mais si l'on
encroit son action au Proche Orient ce
dernier détient-il encore vraiment une
voix sur la scène internationale
pourtant vous êtes le premier à savoir
qu'en ignorant l'obstacle posé par cet
accord bilatéral votre projet de loi est
non seulement insuffisant mais surtout
incomplet or pour paraphraser votre
collègue Emmanuel Vass il est urgent de
mettre en place un bras de fer avec
l'Algérie et ce n'est pas votre ancien
Premier ministre Édouard Philippe qui me
contredirait si l'on en croit ces
dernières prise de position sur cette
question dès lors monsieur le ministre
France va-t-elle dénoncer cet accord
franco-algérien à défaut de suivre les
recommandations du RN nous pouvons au
moins espérer que vous tiendrez en
compte celle qui émerge de vos rangs je
vous remercie merci beaucoup la parole
est à Madame Laurence B ministre en
charge de
l'Europe merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Giletti permettez-moi
peut-être de
remettre cet accord dans un peu de
contexte d'abord la relation entre la
France et l'Algérie ne s'arrête pas à
l'aspect migratoire c'est un élément
important mais elle ne résume pas du
tout la richesse des relations entre nos
deux pays ensuite nous sommes en train
nous sommes dans un travail avec nos
partenaires algériens pour approfondir
cette relation dans l'esprit de la
déclaration d'Alger pour un partenariat
renouvelé entre la France et l'Algérie
qui comme vous savez a été signé par les
deux présidents français et algériens en
2022 nous allons aller de l'avant avec
cet approfondissement mais nous sommes
vigilants et nous allons être
spécialement vigilants dans le domaine
consulaire et dans la délivrance de
laisser passer pour les étrangers en
situation irrégulière et sous le coup
d'une qtf et c'est dans ce contexte
qu'il faut reprendre l'accord de
1968 que vous citez et que nous prenons
en compte dans notre
relation la dénonciation sèche de cet
accord elle n'est pas pertinente tant
pour des raisons juridiques que pour des
raisons politiques elle ne réglerait pas
du tout les difficultés comme vous le
prétendez mais au contraire elle aurait
beaucoup d'inconvénients majeurs et nous
serions collectivement perdants mais cet
accord n'est pas figé il a évolué à
plusieurs reprises par le passé et c'est
bien dans cet esprit que nous allons
travailler pour améliorer les choses
dans le cadre existant je suis sûr que
vous conviendra avec moi que c'est la
voix de la
responsabilité merci beaucoup madame la
ministre parole est à Monsieur Fabrice
le vigoureux pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur Gabriel
Atal ministre de l'éducation nationale
et de la jeunesse monsieur le ministre
vous êtes en charge d'une des plus
belles missions de notre République
celle de l'école celle de la réussite de
nos enfants de leur épanouissement de
leur savoirs parmi ces savoirs il y a
les plus fondamentaux dont dépendent
tous les autres le français et les
mathématiques et notamment la lecture si
essentielle à l'esprit critique à
l'enrichissement du langage à la
créativité et même comme beaucoup
d'études le révèlent aujourd'hui aux
aptitudes émotionnelles et social comme
l'empathie le sens du dialogue de la
nuance et de la tempérance même s'ils
ont tendance à se stabiliser ou même à
progresser à l'entrée en 6e nos
résultats ne sont pas bons en la matière
et sont inégalitaires comme nous le
constatons à longueur d'audition avec ma
collègue Annie Genevard dans le cadre de
notre mission d'information sur
l'apprentissage de la lecture et comme
nous le confirme nombreux d'études
internationales et nationales PISA
aujourd'hui ou même la journée défense
et citoyenneté qui révèle que plus d'un
jeune sur 5 a de très grandes
difficultés en lecture les vents
contraires sont nombreux des réseaux
sociaux aux algorithmes fous qui
abrutissent dès le plus jeune âge des
écrans récréatifs maltraitants qui
détournent des pratiques de lecture et
qui dévorent 2700 heures de la vie d'un
élève de 4e l'équivalent de 3o années
scolaires des formations initiales qui
préparent mal nos enseignants au
meilleur Prat pédagogique l'absence vous
l'avez dit de Manuel dans les classes
monsieur le ministre après d'intenses
consultations avec les principaux acteur
de l'éducation et une enquête à laquelle
230000 enseignants ont contribué vous
êtes déterminés à créer un véritable
choc des savoirs pouvez-vous ici nous en
relater les grands chapitres et ce que
vous envisagez plus spécifiquement pour
faire du livre un compagnon de route de
nos enfants et de la lecture une porte
ouverte vers la culture élément pation
je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Gabriel Atal ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député le vigoureux la
question d'Isabelle roche tout à l'heure
m'a permis de parler des mathématiques
vous me permettez d'aborder une question
fondamentale qui est celle de la lecture
et on parle souvent des savoirs
fondamentaux la lecture et les
mathématiques mais en réalité s'il y en
est un qui est plus fondamental que tous
les autres c'est bien la sûr ne pas
répondre à un problème de mathématique
si on n'est pas capable d'en lire
l'énoncé et oui nous constatons encore
trop de difficultés chez nos élèves en
lecture et en écriture et merci d'avoir
rappelé que nous avons connu des progrès
ces dernières années à l'école primaire
grâce à l'action résolue de cette
majorité la dernière étude pearls qui a
été transmise en mai dernier
international montre que la France est
le seul pays dont les élèves progressent
en CM1 sur cette question là ce qui
montre que les choix que nous avons fait
depuis 2017 sont les bons il faut
maintenant poursuivre amplifier je salue
travail que vous menez avec la députée
Annie jeunevar dans le cadre de votre
mission sur la lecture j'ai pu regarder
à distance les auditions que vous avez
réalisé les piste qui semble se dessiner
pour votre mission et je crois
profondément qu'on se rejoint on se
rejoint sur la nécessité absolue d'avoir
des manuels scolaires labellisé avec des
méthodes prouvées par la science et la
pratique comme efficace à
l'apprentissage de la lecture et
d'écriture pour tous nos élèves en CP et
en CE1 c'est ce que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'annoncer aujourd'hui mais je le dis il
faudra aller beaucoup plus loin sur
l'entrée et l'éveill à la lecture dès
les premières années de la vie on
partage cet objectif avec Rima abdoumak
je le dis avec la place des écrans
aujourd'hui chez les plus jeunes nous
sommes devant une catastrophe sanitaire
et éducative il faut absolument
redresser la barre un élève de moins de
6 ans un enfant de moins de 6 ans passe
aujourd'hui quasiment autant d'heur
devant un écran dans l'année qu'en
classe il faut absolument que nous
soyons capable de renforcer l'éveil à la
lecture à travers des livres qui sont
fournis aux élèves et c'est ce à quoi
nous travaillons notamment en lien avec
les bibliothèques évidemment ça se
poursuit ensuite au collège et au lycée
avec les mesures que j'ai annoncé un
renforcement du volume horaire en
français des groupes de niveau dans
cette discipline pour faire progresser
tous nos élèves oui c'est un enjeu
absolument fondamental et je vous
remercie de nous accompagner dans cette
direction merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Marianne
maximi pour la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Madame cobel
secrétaire d'État chargé de l'enfance
qui a dit la protection de l'enfance
sera au cœur des 5 années qui viennent
c'est Emmanuel Macron et pratiquement 2
ans après que s'est-il passé rien pire
la situation se dégrade de jour en jour
la Défenseur des droits et l'ONU alerte
les professionnels les magistrats mes
collègues éducateurs spécialisés les
pédopsychiatres les assistants
familiales les associations d'enfants
placés toutes et tous alertent la
protection de l'enfant s'est
littéralement effondrée les mesures de
placement ne sont plus mises en œuvre
des enfants en danger restent au
domicile des parents alors que le juge
ordonne leur protection tous les jours
la presse couvre les professionnels qui
craquent les sureffectifs dans les
structures les maltraitances
institutionnelles les infanticides un
enfant meurt tous les 5 jours dans notre
pays ces dernières semaines nous avons
franchi un nouveau cap quatre
départements de droite annoncent
fièrement ne plus respecter la loi ils
suspendent la protection des enfants
étranger et pas pour des raisons
financières parce qu'ils sont en
excédent budgétaire mais pour des
raisons racistes de préférence
nationale et vous que faites-vous quand
on vous demande des comptes vous nous
répondez d'attendre mais attendre quoi
l'application de la loi taqué voté il y
a 2 ans mais toujours sans décret
d'application attendre vos prochaines
annonces absurdes comme par exemple la
réforme qui va faire les poches des
enfants placés en diminuant leur pécule
que faites-vous à part des campagnes de
communication hashtag pour nos enfants
pendant que la défiance envers l'aide
sociale à l'enfance augmente excellent
thoro du complotisme nous n'avons plus
de mots pour porter à vos oreilles la
catastrophe que nous vivons le décalage
entre vos paroles les lois et la réalité
est
insupportable madame la ministre nous
exigeons un plan d'urgence avec des
moyens pour augmenter les salaires pour
recruter pour ouvrir des places nous
exigeons le respect de la loi et la
protection de tous les enfants quel que
soit leur département ou leur
nationalité alors agissez merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Charlotte cobel
Ministre en charge de
l'enfance merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés madame la
députée maximie vous l'avez dit nous ne
vous avons pas attendu pour mesurer
l'étendue de la crise qui ne date pas de
2017 sur la protection de l'enfance vous
l'avez dit le président de la République
a décidé d'en faire la priorité du
quinquena qui s'est traduit par la mise
en place d'un comité interministériel
qui s'est déjà tenu trois fois et dans
lequel nous avons pris des engagements
que nous mesurons au quotidien 26
milliards d'euros auront été mis par ce
gouvernement et par cette majorité au
profit des enfants le plus vulnérabl
c'est de l'argent mis au profit de la
santé des enfants c'est de l'argent mis
au profit des enfants en situation de
handicap c'est de l'argent mis sur le
plan de lutte contre les violences et
c'est de l'argent mis au titre de la
prévention et de l'action vous me
reprochez des coups de communication je
vous reproche votre vindique et votre
communication essentiellement agressive
qui contribue à porter atteinte à
l'image de la protection de l'enfance
tous les jours au quotidien je suis sur
le terrain pour mettre en valeur les
bonnes pratiques de la protection de
l'enfance pour mettre en valeur les
belles histoires de la protection de
l'enfance et pour apporter le soutien de
l'administration et du gouvernement avec
de l'argent sonnant et trébuchant et
avec des actions extrêmement concrètes
de nombreux décrets d'application de la
loi taqué ont été pris simplement nous
sommes dans un dialogue constructif avec
les départements pour la première fois
la première ministre de ce gouvernement
a annoncé un temps fort en terme de
protection de l'enfance avec les
départements à l'occation de l'assemblée
générale des départements nous aurons un
temps politique dans dans quelques jours
où l'ensemble des départements
représentatifs et le gouvernement dans
ses actions les plus concrètes se
réunira pour fixer des priorités et des
engagements réciproques nous agissons
pour tous les enfants je suis sur le
terrain pour mesurer ça nous étions C
ministres tout à l'heure à recevoir le
livre blanc du du travail social pour
nous engager nous sommes sur tous les
plans mais pardonnez-moi si parfois nous
montrons pas suffisamment notre action
et nous n nous ne contendons pas
d'invective et d'insulte merci beaucoup
madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame Josiane
cornelou pour le groupe présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des solidarités et des familles le
Secours populaire français la
Croix-Rouge les banques alimentaires les
restaurants du cœur subissent depuis 1
an la crise inflationniste que nous
connaissons de nombreux publics nouveaux
les sollicitent désormais pour obtenir
une aide alimentaire près de 9 millions
de personnes en France éprouvent
aujourd'hui des difficultés à
s'alimenter
convenablement de plus une augmentation
alarmante des charges logistiques et
d'achat menace leur existence même la
première ministre en novembre 2022 a
annoncé l'attribution de 60 millions
d'euros pour le fond visant à une aide
alimentaire durable ce fond s'est
concrétisé en mai 202 3 par la mise en
œuvre du plan mieux manger pour tous
tous ont pris acte de façon positive de
ce nouveau fond qui allait leur
permettre de renforcer leurs très
nombreuses actions menées sur le terrain
pour une amélioration de la qualité
alimentaire or au 19 octobre 2023 ils
n'ont pu se saisir de toutes les
opportunités pour mieux aider les plus
précaires sur le plan alimentaire car
aucun fond n'est arrivé alors que
l'inflation à elle bien continuer de
progresser par ailleurs le commissaire
européen Nicolas Schmid membre de la
Commission européenne emploi et droits
sociaux interrogé par ces mêmes
associations a indiqué qu'une partie
importante de la dotation française au
titre du féad Fond européen d'aide au
plus démunis
2014-2020 n'avait pas encore fait
l'objet d'appel de fond de la France
auprès de la Commission européenne or la
fin de la période d'éligibilité des
actions pour le féad est fixé au 31
décembre 2023 il est donc plus qu'urgent
de capter ce potentiel financier restant
aujourd'hui 5 décembre en cette Journée
mondiale du bénévolat je veux saluer
toutes les personnes qui ne comptent ni
leur temps ni leur peine pour aider les
autres il serait incompréhensible pour
eux que cet argent soit perdu je porte
ici madame la ministre la voix des
associations qui aident les plus démunis
tout au long de l'année et qui attendent
des réponses tant sur les annonces de la
Premier ministre que sur le féad merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame Aurore
berger ministre des solidarité et des
familles merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Josiane cornelou il n'y aura
évidemment pas un seul euro qui manquera
c'est l'engagement que nous avons pris
sur la question de l'aide alimentaire et
c'est l'engagement qui sera tenu nous
avons d'ailleurs à nouveau reçu le
président des Restos du cœur hier avec
Bruno Le Maire pour lui redire très
clairement qu'évidemment suite à l'appel
d'ailleurs qu'il avait lancé en
septembre dernier l'engagement du
gouvernement serait tenu deux questions
que vous posez la première sur le F la
deuxième sur mieux manger pour tout sur
le féad il faut savoir que ça n'est pas
l'Union européenne la Commission
européenne qui délègue des crédits la
France doit d'abord dépenser et ensuite
la France est remboursée ce qui provoque
un décalage en fait sur les délais de
paiement donc il n'y a pas d'argent
caché ou qui ne serait pas allé être
récupéré par la France au contraire tous
les crédits que nous pouvions avoir nous
sommes allés évidemment les chercher en
en lien avec France agrimaire en
particulier donc évidemment nous allons
continuer à le faire et puis il y a le
programme mieux manger pour tous dont
vous avez signalé d'ailleurs que les
associations se félicitient de la
nouvelle manière avec laquelle nous
avons travaillé pourquoi parce que
traditionnellement les associations
elles faisaient appel à la ramasse à des
invendus à la lutte contre le gaspillage
c'est très bien mais les personnes les
plus vulnérables c'est aussi un enjeu
d'égalité de santé publique doivent
avoir accès à une alimentation de
qualité à des produits frais à des
produits locaux ça tombe bien en plus
nous avons l'agriculture la plus saine
et la plus durable au monde donc autant
faire en sorte évidemment que ce soit
possible il y a 1200 candidats qui ont
demandé à bénéficier du plan mieux
manger pour tous 479 ont été retenus et
tous les crédits seront engagés avant la
fin de l'année toutes les associations
bénéficiaires le seront j'ajoute à cela
que sur les 60 millions d'euros du mieux
manger pour tous 20 millions d'euros
désormais sont des crédits locaux pour
aider finement les plus petites
associations partout dans les
territoires partout dans les
départements pour les accompagner et que
l'an prochain ce n'est pas 60 millions
d'euros mais 70 millions d'euros qui
existeront pour mieux manger pour tous
donc on continue notre engagement sur
l'aide alimentaire et le soutien au plus
vulnérables je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la ministre la séance
des questions au Gouvernement est
terminée la séance est
suspendue